Stop studying for JLPT
Don't rent a Japanese girlfriend, make a death sightseeing
If you watch Doraemon, he's
like Gian Sorry, what is Gian?
What do you think? Well, I
inhale audibly. I work diligently. I deny it in a roundabout way. No, it's not that I don't
like it.
But what can I say? I had a great time
traveling to New York with Ross. Next time I'd like to
go to Hawaii.  Check, then
check again just to be sure. Buy a
microwave that makes a beeping sound instead of B. Buy a
blue tarp. It has to be blue.
Instead of someone who brazenly steals books, buy a
product that you browse through.  Add eco mode
Adjust your eyebrows Divide the food that fits on one plate into 4 plates
Learn to cut things with chopsticks
Say your first words Transfer all the money in your investment account
to your insurance account Make your brain think of every word you say.  Well,
I was surprised.No, I totally agree.Oh, it looks like it's going to be
fun.Yes, that's right.I'm going to make the
glass smaller when I drink water.I'm going to
study English again.Is this an opportunity for me to study?
Next time I'm going to Los Angeles.When I use my power.  I'm
always going to say the cliché, ok, TNK
SRS I'm going to skip the rare day off and
spend it shopping for souvenirs for my co-workers. I'm fine
with shrimp rice crackers, but I'm going to hire Mr. Suzuki and
start shopping for a notebook that I don't want to polish.
Praise.  forgetting how to understand words